but none of that that was uttered
recently by sean mcvay should be
regarded as a slap
at his former quarterback jared goff
even though it was
now sean mcveigh tells albert breer of
si.com that
matthew stafford is a bad mf even better
than advertised he's even more excited
mcveigh
is now that he's had a chance to work
with matthew stafford and for good
reason he comes in at number eight
on the chris sims quarterback countdown
i remember
when we first started working together
the first time you did this list you had
matthew stafford at three which was
stunning to me and some would say it's
stunning he's still in the top ten it's
so easy for him to be
forgotten yes in detroit and and that's
the thing that
is going to be fascinating this year
because it's not like peyton manning
going from indianapolis to denver
it's like peyton manning going from
cleveland to denver if cleveland had
been bad the whole time he was with the
browns
we don't know how this guy's gonna
translate to a good team because he's
never really been on one he had a few
playoff appearances but they've never
won a playoff game they won a playoff
game in 30 years so
it's gonna be a hell of an experiment to
see what stafford can bring to a team
that got
to the final eight last year with jared
goff and john wolford at quarterback
right i mean got to the final eight but
like you know that was one of the
downfalls of their team they had to like
micromanage the quarterback position
to get to the final eight i'm i'm
expecting this to be the year matthew
stafford
yeah you know i've been a big fan of him
for a long time
the talent's real he's like the poster
child to say you need a team
you need help around you you know
there's we we've talked about this a
million times
there's never been a running game
there's never been anything special to
why people
think matt stafford should have better
results or more playoff wins
you know and that wasn't but but he had
he had in dominican sue and calvin jones
oh my gosh
multiple years okay three guys three
i mean we can't name anybody else
there's nothing else to talk about on
the football team that's it
three i can name other quarterbacks and
go you got three hall of famers that you
throw the ball to
or on this one side of the ball you have
four hall of famers so
that's where i know and it's tough but
like he's an
incredible incredible talent and still
one of the most
game-changing arms in football that's
where stafford is really
special he makes more off
platform you know different platform
awkward throws
that go unnoticed just because we're so
used to seeing it and we're thinking oh
he's just doing it to be cool
no he's not doing it to be cool he's
doing it because he always has to do it
because his team hasn't been very good
he doesn't want to throw a 40-yard
sidearm laser
he has to a lot of the times because
people are around him and he only has a
window that he has to throw a ball from
his right knee
to get it 40 yards and he does it and we
just like we don't even think
twice about it you know he's really
amazing that way
he and another guy tough as nails plays
through
injury you know phenomenal not gonna say
a great
runner but a phenomenal mover again like
a baker mayfield can move around the
pocket and make
so many crazy throws and things where he
can torch his body
like a mahomes when it comes to the
throwing stuff and all that
and here's the other thing that goes
unnoticed with me mike too
like you know he'll throw a ball
quicker than he wants to or other
quarterbacks will
like he'll let's just say he sees that
post going down the middle of the field
wide open you know other quarterbacks
will be like all right wait let me
finish my
drop and set up and throw it stafford
will be like whoa
he's open i'm supposed to take four more
steps in my drop
but i'm just gonna lay on my back foot
and sling it to him right now and get it
to him quick so we can maximize
everything that's there to be had for
this play
or this route or whatever and those are
things that i look at always and go
man it's special he's a game changer in
offense and what he does because of his
talents and what he brings there
and you know i do think this is going to
be the year of matt stafford where
finally everybody realizes damn
this guy's good he's got a team around
him finally and an offense that's kind
of damn good too
and here we go so i'm hoping for that
big time in a big way
very quietly chris he's currently number
16
on the all-time passing yardage list
ahead of dan phelps
ahead of joe montana ahead of jim kelly
ahead of johnny united and this year
barring injury he will pass vinnie
testaverdi
carson palmer fran tarkenton and with
4216 yards
he will pass warren moon and move
into 11th all-time on the passing
yardage list with one more year
of 4 200. and he's 32.
and he's got plenty of football left to
play and he could end up among
the all-time greats by the time he's
done has there ever been a guy
and i was looking at this list to try to
jog my memory yeah
a guy who spent so much time with a team
that wasn't good
who got a chance to go to an elite team
at this stage of his career i can't
think of another one where it's this
stark
you put together those great stats with
a team that's never won a playoff game
during your career
and now you land with a team that just
won a playoff game last year in seattle
of all places which is one of the
toughest places to win
and got to the divisional round this is
unprecedented it is unless i'm missing
someone
no i i think you're right you know it's
unprecedented
listen this this guy i can't tell you
how many coaches i talk to
and i know i've told you this behind the
scenes and i think we talked about it a
little bit
hey when stafford was made available
there was i i think the league when they
started to study
stafford for the trade and whoa wait you
know detroit's gonna make him
i think the league was taken back by a
little bit about how talented he was i
could say that i i've talked to
four different coaches who were like you
know
i i always do stafford was talented but
you know i i don't study them we're not
in the nfc
north so i only see him every few years
all that type of stuff
where they broke down and studied and
they were like whoa
he's way better than i realized way
better than the public gives them
you know credit for and you know again
just think this is what matt stafford
does a little bit
kenny gallaudet was hurt most of the
year last year marvin jones is up there
in years banged up a little bit there's
no run game
not a special line below average defense
i mean nothing to talk about in detroit
nothing
and you look at their schedule and i
just want to go first off and people and
just go like
well what games were they supposed to
win tell me what team you thought that
they were better than
and then i sit there and also go you
know this is what a matt stafford can do
and you know people will get lost and go
oh they're you know they're 5 and 11 or
whatever else i would go well they were
going to be 2 and 14 if it's not for
matt stafford and things like that
but his ability to make magic i mean
they were five and seven at one point
during the year
had just beat the chicago bears who were
six and six who have
way more talent on their roster than the
detroit lions way more
but the greatness of stafford almost
made it look like those teams were equal
and that's what a great quarterback can
do but they've been so bad
we can't even see what he's all really
about and i'm hoping this is the year
okay two questions yeah first
first
if you're the 49ers right would you
would you rather here's the two deals
that you possibly could do
would you rather three first round picks
and a third round pick
to move up to get trey lance or
two ones and a three and jimmy garoppolo
to get matthew stafford oh i would have
gone you know what i would i would have
gotten
i would have gone that second option
yeah i'd i'd
you know i think matt stafford is just
he's one of those guys it's just it's
waiting to explode if he just can get
the right support system and offense
around him and everything like
that so yeah that would have been my
choice and especially like you know we
talked about a few minutes ago
it's a guy that's 32 you know he's he's
got at least
five six years left of really good
football play and has one of those arms
mike that you know we talk about it's
it's never going to die out he's going
to be 78 in a rocking chair and still
going to be able to throw balls and like
you're going to be like whoa
matt stever could still throw the
football it's a timeless arm
and he's got unbelievable play-making
ability and that's where i think you see
like the mcvay stuff where he's like
you know i'm happy and all this stuff
because he's like one
hey practice is better you know there's
laser beams going everywhere they're
accurate they're on money
and now he doesn't have to worry about
weight like oh wait
i can't call this play or i can't do
this because my quarterback isn't great
at throwing this right
there's like no limitations you've taken
the handcuffs off of
sean mcvay to where now he is back to
being a mad scientist going
wait this guy run this way this guy run
that way i don't even have to worry wait
he's 74 yards over here
who cares stafford can throw it let's
draw the play up let's do it
and that's that's like great freedom and
i think that's why you see the mcveigh
quotes because he's seeing this in
in person going oh my gosh my life's
gonna be a lot easier
that i don't have to micromanage the
quarterback position anymore
and i agree with you if i'm the 49ers
i'd rather have stafford and also
unload jimmy garoppolo and frankly i
think that
they probably could have gotten that
deal for less than two ones in a three
in offloading jimmy garoppolo because
jimmy garoppolo
arguably more attractive yeah right
given his contract given his contract
than than jared goff um here's my here's
my other and i don't want to rain on the
parade here no i want to balance this
out yeah because there's something
that's nagged at me about matthew
stafford and and
it first started when 2012
2013-ish they were struggling
reggie bush who had won a super bowl
with the saints wanted to have a
players only meeting and staffers like
now we don't need that
there's just always been this reluctance
from stafford to be the guy that helped
tom brady get to number 10
right to be the guy that goes to the guy
who's crying in the locker room after
you make it to the super bowl and say
you
no no no no no we got more work to do
teammate
we got more that we're trying to
accomplish i've always felt like matthew
stafford has not
had not wanted to have yeah the
intangibles
the leadership because i i plain and
simple
he tolerated detroit for 12 years yeah i
know
the mere fact that a guy with that
talent level tolerated that organization
for 12 years tells me something's not
right there
well because if it was peyton manning do
you think peyton manning would have
stayed in detroit for 12 years
hell no do you think tom brady would
have stayed in detroit for 12 years
hell no he would have either changed it
or given up
and said get me the hell out of here at
some point over the last 12 years i just
feel like stafford
he just he doesn't have that same fire
that we celebrate
in guys like manning and brady
no i agree i'm not going to disagree
with you a whole lot there i think
there's more than he gets credit for i
think we've seen a little bit more the
last few years
i do think that was the positive thing
matt patricia and company brought to him
uh
brought to his game a little bit a
little bit more of a general
attitude he does yell at people and do
those type of things
you know but also like you know he i
think you could also look at it mike and
go yeah he's not happy he's doing
everything he could he's playing awesome
he is the kind of guy that i think also
believes in his talents and is probably
like yeah we're gonna turn this around
he never had a bill pauline or tony
dungy or anybody or a bill
bill belichick or anybody at some point
at some point before 2020 when you're
drafted in 2009 you say enough
get me the hell out of here i can't do
this anymore
yeah i you know not everybody's wired
that way you know
and again i guess that's what we're
you're questioning whether that's
the guy he can be we'll see i know i
think that's something though
that is in players that has to be
brought out
i do i do in a lot of cases brady yeah
he was that but we weren't hearing those
stories in michigan and nor the rookie
year
we heard them once he started playing he
got good and the belichick effect and
all those things
peyton okay peyton was special yeah we
heard those stories in college and
probably high school he's probably like
omaha this omaha that
you're screwing up my offense i mean
peyton's special he's
i don't know what else to say he's
amazing that way but stafford i do
here's a side of it here's the other
side of it
you don't need it if you have other
leaders if you have others
right and maybe in la they'll have that
that's that's where i think
he's got some other voices with ramsey
you know aaron donald and of course
mcveigh but i also think
you know mcveigh is going to bring it
out of him
i do because i think he's going to be
like man the offense is perfect he's
taught me it perfect
mcveigh's on me and on the offense he
wants to be me to be an extension of him
and i i will be shocked if we don't see
a little bit more of like what you're
talking about
out of matthew stafford this year but i
don't think he's been afforded the
luxury like
a lot of the great quarterbacks in the
history of the sport to have that
guy around him to push him to be that
you know whether it was brady and he had
you know chuck noll
i mean phil sims had bill parcells bill
walsh was the biggest pain in the ass in
the world to joe montana
never really made them feel respected or
great that way they brought it out in
them to be that jerk
you know to be the leader of the team
and do that type of stuff
and that's where i just look at him and
go he's never he's never had anybody
like that
never a great offensive mind nothing
special
ever has been around except for calvin
johnson and dominic and sue
and that's just not going to win games
for you two other guys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports